-I have heard this is great.
-No, this is your play.
This is your play.
Yeah, "Gutenberg! The Musical!"
-Yes.
-I want to talk to you
about this.
You were on our show
when we did "Late Night"
and back when you guys
were in "Book of Mormon."
-"Book of Mormon."
-Yes. Do you remember that?
-Uh-huh.
-You were --
It was the funniest thing
I've ever seen on Broadway.
-Thank you.
I go, "Oh, my gosh, this is
the funniest thing ever."
-Until now.
-Now you're back.
Now you're back, everybody.
Yeah, until now is right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you like that?
This is our big reunion
on Broadway.
-I was waiting.
I was like, "What are these guys
gonna do together?
They have to do --"
Your chemistry was so great.
I go -- And I have a great idea,
I think.
I want you to do
a detective show on TV.
-Oh.
-That doesn't feel like
something either of us
wants to do.
-Yeah.
No, this is great.
This is what you have to do.
-Okay.
-And it's like a "Matlock"
type of thing.
-Oh, okay.
-Alright. Tell me more.
-Oh, see, I was going
"Murder, She Wrote."
-Yeah, that's what makes it fun.
You can do "Murder, She Wrote."
You can do "Matlock."
-So this is sort of
like a hybrid.
Do you want us in the same show
here, or is this -- Okay.
-Yes. I want to see you
in the same show.
-What about like
a "Simon & Simon"?
-That makes more sense.
That makes more sense.
[ Laughter ]
"Simon & Simon,"
you can do that, as well.
But I want to see that.
I think that would be
kind of fun to watch.
-Alright, yeah, it sounds
like your audience
is really excited
about that one, too.
It feels like
this could be a hit.
-In the meantime,
if you don't have
the detective show,
you have
"Gutenberg! The Musical!"
-We have
-You can both sing and dance.
You're very talented.
-He can sing and dance
really well.
-You can also sing and dance.
You know, it's been a long time
since we've done
a show together.
-Do you remember first meeting?
What were your first impressions
of each other?
-Didn't like the guy very much.
-No, no, no.
We can edit this out.
We can edit all this out.
-Oh, Andrew.
-Oh, great. Me.
-We met June 2010.
-Look at this guy.
Dear diary.
-That was so sweet.
-They flew him to L.A.
And we did a -- we did a --
-I can do this for hours.
I love this.
-Well, this is going to be
on our detective show.
This is how we hold each other.
-Ooh! I'm excited.
I'm telling you, Peacock.
-So, Andrew came in.
Andrew -- Peacock.
-Yeah.
-Andrew came in,
and I had done workshops
with other people
like three or four times,
and then they brought
two celebrities up against --
stacked him
against two big celebs.
And then he came in last.
And we did the scene together.
It was Cunningham and Price.
And I looked at Trey Parker,
Matt Stone,
and our producer,
Anne Garefino, after,
and I said, "That's the guy."
And they said, "We agree.
Why do you think that way?"
And I said,
"Because it's the first time
I've ever been intimidated
by an Elder Price."
-Josh.
-And he was incredible.
He was absolutely incredible.
-Was that part of the secret?
-I threatened him,
which was part
of the temptation factor.
No, it was very --
it was very intimidating.
And I remember very clearly,
you know, obviously,
getting to read.
But we didn't have any time
together before.
We just, like,
walked into a room
and then had to start
reading together.
So it was, like --
it was very intimidating.
But the two guys
who went in before me
were pretty damn famous.
-Did you see them
leave the room?
-Yeah, 'cause we were all there
at the same time.
-I don't like that.
-But I figured --
I was like, "I don't
really have a shot."
-Suffice it to say Al Pacino
did not get the role.
-Oh, no, don't say his name.
Don't say his name.
-But I figured -- I was like,
"I don't have a shot
at this at all."
And then one of the guys
walked out and he looked at me
and he said,
"Musicals are hard."
[ Laughter ]
-But he said it like this.
[ As Pacino ]
Musicals are hard.
-Oh, wow. It's Al Pacino.
-[ Normal voice ] I was like,
"Albert, calm down, man."
-[ As Pacino ]
Musicals are hard.
I don't like musicals.
-Musicals are hard.
-If you want to do
a detective show, I'm your guy.
-[ Normal voice ]
Oh, wait. No.
-Very good, right?
-You guys should do the show.
But let's talk about
"Gutenberg! The Musical!"
James Earl Jones Theatre
right now.
And this is something --
People have called it the
"Hamilton" of its generation.
-[ Normal voice ]
Well, that's me.
I'm the person.
-Yeah.
I don't think anyone else
is saying that.
-Even though technically,
"Hamilton" is the "Hamilton"
of our generation.
-Right now it is, yeah.
-I think this is the "Hamilton"
of its generation.
-You said that.
-Yes.
-I think this is the "Cats"
of this generation.
-It's a slightly
different premise
than "Cats" or "Hamilton."
-It's "Cats"
by way of "Hamilton"
with two would-be detectives.
-"Wicked."
You like "Wicked,"
you'll love this.
-If you guys love musicals,
this is for you.
-This is for you.
-This is the one.
-"Gutenberg"
with these two guys.
In the show, you actually --
you wear a lot of hats.
-We do.
-You play every character
in the whole show.
-Yes.
-So there are about 120 hats...
-That's me.
That's Andrew.
-That's right.
-...that we wear
throughout the show
to sort of differentiate
these different characters
that we play.
There's about --
-There's over 120 hats.
-Yeah.
-And, by the way,
I found out about the hats
after I signed up.
I would not have done a show
with hats had I known,
'cause there are two things
that scare me --
hats and choreography.
The show has both.
-This is a nightmare then, yeah.
-But to be clear,
we had done two readings
of this musical
before we, you know,
were really going to do it
in earnest here on Broadway.
And Josh claims
that he had no idea
that there were hats involved,
except there is a mention
of hats all over the script.
-I don't read stage directions.
-He doesn't read
stage directions.
-You don't read the script.
-My character never says,
"I'm wearing a hat right now."
-He just sort of scanned
for his character's name.
-So I wouldn't know,
so I wouldn't think.
-You wouldn't know.
But what happens when someone
grabs the wrong hat?
-Oh, this happened
the other night.
-It happens.
Sometimes the hats fall off.
Sometimes, you know --
-This past week, we've had a hat
fly into the audience.
There was a day where --
Do any of you watch
"Only Murders in the Building"?
You know that scene -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One of the best
detective shows...
-One of the best detective shows
of all time.
-...on television right now.
That's what people are watching.
-It's a weird Jimmy obsession
right now.
But, yes, this detective show.
-America wants you guys
to do the detective show
"Only Murders in the Building."
You guys love
"Only Murders in the Building"?
How about with these guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, like, Steve Martin,
I went to the white room
and I found myself holding a hat
I've never held
in my entire life.
And I looked at Andrew onstage,
and this is
my version of improv.
I go, "Andrew, what the hell
am I doing with this hat?"
I had, like, no --
I had no improv for it.
-There's no game face.
-No, there's no game face.
-That's how you improvised?
-Yeah. I go, "What do I do now?"
Or he'll say, "I wasn't
supposed to say that,"
or, "You weren't
or, "Where am I?"
-You just call him out?
-Sort of just, like,
blunt-force improv.
So I said this to him,
and he goes,
"No, put that back
where you found it."
[ Laughter ]
-We got back on track.
-Of course you
get back on track.
-It's live theater, Jimmy.
-I was very lucky to meet
your mom and dad
and your brother backstage.
-They were very lucky
to meet you.
-No, come on.
But you know what's funny?
We were talking, and you guys
were nice enough to come on
when I hosted "Late Night"
back in the day.
This is us here, in fact.
-Oh, look at this.
-2012.
-That's me.
That's Andrew.
-No, that's is -- that's you.
And your mom said that it was
one of her favorite --
-My mom. I have done --
I have done a bunch
of late night since that.
For some reason --
Probably 2,500.
And for some reason,
my mother always says to me,
"I'll never forget the time
you and Andrew sang
'Take On Me' with Jimmy Fallon.
It was my favorite."
-That's right.
-That's right, Mom. Mom is --
-Susan Gad's here.
-My mom is here. Susan.
-Susan Gad Schwartz is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aw, look at Mom and Dad.
-Look at that. Come on.
-Mom and Dad.
-She has great taste.
-Oh, Mama.
-But I thought it'd be kind of
fun, if you wouldn't mind,
to maybe re--
-Should we do it?
-I mean, sure.
-I think it's time.
Mom, this is for you.
-This is for Susan.
-This is for you, Susan.
[ "Take On Me" plays ]
-Oh, yeah.
Do you remember this, Jimmy?
-♪ Talking away ♪
♪ I don't know what I'm to say ♪
♪ I'll say it anyway ♪
♪ Today is another day
to find you ♪
♪ Shyin' away ♪
♪ I'll be comin'
for your love, okay ♪
-♪ Take on me ♪
-♪ Take me on ♪
-♪ I'll be gone ♪
-This one's for you, Mama.
♪ In a day or two ♪
-Josh Gad and Andrew Rannells.
"Gutenberg! The Musical!"
is on Broadway
at the James Earl Jones Theatre
through January 28th.
We're playing a new game
with them after the break.
Come on back, everybody.
♪ Take on me ♪
-I love you, Mama.
-♪ Take me on ♪
-♪ Take on me ♪
-♪ I'll be gone ♪